le groupe CT est implanté sur le
territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines plus
précisément à Guyancourt c'est un groupe
espagnol et je suis avec le CO de ce
groupe CT David Prieto bonsoir bonsoir
alors déjà un mot sur c'était et c'était
une générique en pourquoi c'est
important d'être présent sur le salon du
Bourget et donc c'était c'est familial
designeries nous a presque à 10000
collaborateurs en Europe et c'est un
groupe de capital espagnol mais avec un
très faux stratégie dans la France donc
nous sommes présentés à San le rouget
parce que nous sommes en 2015 et
soustratrons des premières Nivelles de
du argus donc c'était beau tamponneuse
spécialement et avec les cartons qui ont
passé entre les covid et maintenant
alors Airbus vous venez de le mentionner
l'un de vos principaux
aisance sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines Airbus defense and space à
Élancourt pourquoi c'était important de
venir sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est récent
c'est 2019 que vous êtes venus sur le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines elles
sont vraiment contents avec cette
incorporation là c'était on a une
comparé une activité de le Groupe
Bertrand vous pouvez être Nîmes d'une
calculatrice
de savoir-faire de la partie système qui
est vraiment
avancé dans la partie de nous et c'est
une possibilité très bien dans la partie
espace avec des clients comme Meknès
avec
vous ceci alors
le site est implanté à Guyancourt
combien de personnes travaillent sur ce
site et c'est quoi comme métier qu'on
retrouve sur ce site donc c'est plus ou
moins 50 personnes et on est en train de
grandir encore donc et c'est ici pour
moi des activités de calculs multifices
qui des systèmes donc l'application
industrielle puis ce moment dans la
partie défense la partie arrose aussi il
a participé dans ce très bon temps parce
que c'est vraiment des activités des
très haute valeur ajoutée techno et on a
beaucoup de docteurs
avec ces décorations on était présent en
Guyancourt et puis alors si vous venez
de dire ça rentre totalement dans la
logique de ce que vous avez signé ce
matin avec l'école l'ESTACA vous avez
signé un partenariat avec l'école
l'ESTACA de Montigny-le-Bretonneux tout
à fait et ça c'est une notion vraiment
croyante dans la les modèles de la
formation du Wall en PC depuis des temps
pour l'Espagne et c'est vraiment de
d'aider à l'étudiante et avec les
colorations avec des écoles comme et de
développer et les capabilités pour être
vraiment et raison dans l'industrie
après soit l'enseignement c'est cas
spécialement on a fait du cours de mbsi
bien sûr pardon que ça veut dire de
système de ça permet que les gens
peuvent venir avec nous pour faire des
tâches puis après rentrer rapidement
dans l'industrie et avoir on n'aime pas
immédiate dans notre cliente dans notre
boîte aussi autre partenariat que vous
avez aussi avec un acteur économique du
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
l'entreprise air captif vers captive qui
appartient au groupe plus important de
Michelin qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
air oui donc ça c'est un projet que
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
c'est c'est sa combine du trou que ça
combine l'espace ça combine aussi la
partie soustabilité donc ça c'est les
projets Insider les produits du soleil
c'est un projet pour aider à
diminuer les derberies spatial donc on a
beaucoup de satellite que sont autour de
moi
il se casse il lui demande de débris
sont de la musette pour être
pour permis que on est plus safe en le
Déménage des nouveaux satellite il y a
les mentons de dire à réduit la
contamination espaciale voilà l'idée
c'est vraiment de capter c'est ça avec
l'aide de la technologie de R4 type
c'est de capter tous les débris pour
éviter de polluer disons
éviter des problèmes tu sais de de
collision de débris avec du nouveau
stade light ça c'est très content
spécialement avec les nouveaux satellite
les mini les constellations
ensemble et on sait compter ils sont
plus petits dans les projets de risque
c'est plus gros que avant un dernier mot
maintenant sur
il y a besoin de main d'oeuvre il y a
besoin de nouveau collaborateurs et vous
êtes en train d'embaucher actuellement
sur le site de Guyancourt
et nous sommes en train de embaucher des
gens pour continuer à s'activer
simulation et produire grandir la France
et bien sûr pour continuer à notre
pression stratégie un gagnanto merci
David Pretto merci pour votre effort
aussi parce que je rappelle vous êtes
espagnol vous êtes le CEO du groupe CT
qui est basé donc à Madrid mais qui est
aussi implanté sur le territoire
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines merci pour
l'effort d'avoir parlé en français